>> Laura: WE LOOK AT THE
CULTURAL STORIES OF THE DAY WE
TURN TO RAYMOND ARROYO.
SOME FEMALE ABORTION ACTIVISTS
HAVE STARTED WITH HER CALLING AS
A STRIKE MOVEMENT.
>> THAT IS CORRECT IF THEY ARE
REFUSING TO HAVE UNTIL ABORTION
RIGHTS ARE FEDERALLY BACK IN TH.
WE CAME TO GET A COMMON MAN'S
REACTION.
>>
>> THERE'S NOT ENOUGH PEOPLE
HORGAN TO DO CYNICAL
AGAINST BECAUSE IT FEELS SO GOOD
IT'S ALSO A BUSINESS.
EVERYONE IS ALWAYS AND WANT TO
HAVE.
>> I GUESS THAT'S GREAT FOR
WOMEN WHO CAN CHOOSE NOT TO
HAVE.
I'M NOT SURE IF IT'S GONNA
CHANGE MUCH.
>> THIS IS ONE OF OUR MOST
POWERFUL PROTESTING OPTION FROM
UNTIL THIS OPTION IS MADE RIGHT.
>> I DON'T THINK THAT IS AN
GREAT WAY TO GET ABORTION BACK.
>> I THINK TO BE MORE AGGRESSIVE
THAN NECESSARY.
THINGS CAN BE LITTLE BACKWARDS.
>> AND NOTHING IS WILLING TO
WORK.
>> I KNOW I BE WILLING TO GIVE
IT A STRIKE IF IT WOULD.
>> I WOULD SAY I AGREE WITH HER.
>> REALLY?
>> DO YOU AGREE WITH IT?
>> I DON'T REALLY HAVE A SAY ON
A STRIKE.
>> ITS WERE A GIRL WILL NOT HAVE
WITH YOU.
>> I THINK IT VARIES FROM PERSON
TO PERSON.
WE HAVE THAT'S A TOUGH ONE.
>> I NOTICE YOU GOT VERY SOBER
AFTER THE NEXT DONATION.
>> NOT SURPRISING.
>> WOMEN OF THE WORLD HAVE
CONDUCTED STRIKES IN HISTORY.
>> WE HAVE MORE POWER THAN SOME
OF US EXPECT A LOT OF IT CAN BE
RIGHT IN THE BEDROOM.
>> I THINK WOMEN HAVE THE RIGHT
TO DO WITH THE BODIES WHATEVER
THEY SAY THEY WANT TO DO.
SO I SUPPORT PEOPLE IN THIS
MOVEMENT.
>> I THINK A STRIKE IS A WAY TO
AWAKEN PEOPLE'S DECISIONS.
>> I DON'T REALLY HAVE AN
OPINION ON THAT.
SO HE WOULD BE OKAY IF YOUR
GIRLFRIEND OR SIGNIFICANT OTHERS
WANT TO STRIKE UNTIL ABORTION IS
LEGAL.
>> I DON'T HAVE A GIRLFRIEND SO
I CAN'T REALLY SAY THAT.
AGAIN IF THEY WANT TO DO THAT
LIVE THEIR LIFE I LOVE THEM I
WILL SUPPORT THEM.
>> YOU BE WILLING TO EMBRACE
CELIBACY?
>> I'M NOT GONNA LIE.
I DON'T KNOW.
>> I DISAGREE WITH THE
ROE V. WADE THING YOU NEED TO
MAKE A DECISION ON WHO CAN HAVE
IT A KID WITH.
PEOPLE ARE SUFFERING FROM THE
ABORTION WE NEED TO MAKE BETTER
DECISIONS OF WHO THEY ARE HAVING
CHILDREN WITH.
>> YOUR REACTION TO THE
SEX TRADE?
>> DO YOU THINK THAT'S
EFFECTIVE?
>> I THINK IT CAN BE BUT AT THE
SAME TIME ARE WOMEN REALLY GONNA
DO THAT?
[LAUGHS]
US BECAUSE THEY HAVE BEEN ON
STRIKE.
WHAT IS THE DIFFERENCE?
>> I HAVE TO TELL YOU THIS WAS
INSIGHTFUL.
FIRST FULL IT'S A PROTEST
BECAUSE A STRIKE REMOVES THE
CONTROVERSY ENTIRELY BECAUSE YOU
DON'T NEED ABORTIONS.
IT WAS SAD WITH THAT GENTLE AND
POINTED OUT THE LONELINESS THAT
THIS RECREATIONAL IS GREATER FOR
THIS GENERATION THE LAST COUPLE
IT SAID BECAUSE HE CAN HAVE
HAPPY AND LOVING FAMILIES.
>> THAT GUY WAS AWESOME.
IS THERE ANY CONSERVATIVE IN
NEW YORK AT ALL.
>> INEXPLICABLY NANCY PELOSI
ATTENDED THE VATICAN TODAY.
THE SPEAKER HAS BEEN FORBIDDEN
FROM PRESENT YOURSELF TO
COMMUNITY IN HER HOME OF SYMPTOM
SCOPE DUE TO HER ADVOCACY FOR
ABORTION STILL THERE SHE WAS
TODAY GLAD-HANDING WITH THE POPE
AND TAKING COMMUNION.
I'VE TO TELL YOU MY PHONE TO
OPEN PEOPLE SAW THIS.
WHAT WE DO THIS IS IMPORTANT IS
WHAT WE SAY.
THE POPE SAYS SHOULD BE A SOURCE
OF UNITY AND A WAY TO PROTECT
HER COMMUNITY I DON'T KNOW HOW
THIS DOES THAT I THINK STRANGEST
PEOPLE FOR WHATEVER THEIR BELIEF
MIGHT BE.
>> Laura: SHE WAS NOT THE ONLY
PUBLIC FIGURE SPEAKING PEACE.
THE CREATOR OF ONE OF TV SHOWS
OF OUR TIME.
SAYS THAT THE SHOW IS NOT
DIVERSE ENOUGH NOW SHE HAS COME
TO A NEW UNDERSTANDING.
>> Laura: IN AN INTERVIEW SHE
SAYS IT'S HER INTERNALIZE
SYSTEMIC RACISM THAT CAUSE A
LACK OF INCLUSIVITY ON A VERY
POPULAR SHOW.
HERE SHE IS DISCUSSING THE
PROBLEM.
>> IT WAS TO A CERTAIN EXTENT A
PRODUCT OF THE TIME.
AT OF MY OWN IGNORANCE.
DORA BLACK-SCHOLES AND THEY WERE
WHITE SHOWS.
THERE WERE A LOT OF SHOWS THAT
WERE INTERRACIAL.
I GUESS OF THE TIME I WAS SAYING
THIS IS WHAT I KNOW.
>> HER INSENSITIVITY OVER THE
SHOW THAT SHE CREATED 28 YEARS
AGO SHE IS DONATING $4 MILLION
TO UNIVERSITY TO FUND
AFRICAN AMERICAN STUDIES.
I KNOW THE STUDY HAS YOU AMPED.
>> Laura: HERE'S WHAT I DON'T
LIKE IS GOING BACK YOU GO BACK
IN TIME AND SAY NO THIS DOESN'T
COUNT, THIS IS BAD.
IT WAS A DIFFERENT TIME.
SHE FEELS THE NEED TO PUBLICLY
HOW MUCH DID SHE MAKE ON FRONTS?
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS MEMBER THEY
GOT THE LAST CONTRACT?
>> 1 MILLION FOR EACH EPISODE SO
IF THE REALLY SERIOUS ABOUT THIS
YET TO GO MORE THAN THE
4 MILLION IS NOT ENOUGH.
>> LOOK SHE CAN SPEND HER MONEY
ANYWAY SHE WANTS.
IF YOU WANT TO HELP THE BACK
BLACK COMMUNITY WHERE YOU GIVEN
$4 MILLION?
HELP THE BLACK COMMUNITY